[Applause]
everybody we are back and uh
a lot of great shows still coming up but
before we go any further i think it's
time we did a little public service we
make fun of a lot of people on the show
and
let's do something nice this is
something we've actually done several
times on the show and it's always been a
big success
uh let me explain a lot of our viewers
at this late hour are moms and dads with
newborn babies
okay and you can imagine they're up late
they're trying to get their newborns to
sleep and they're watching the show
right now well folks this next segment
is just
for you okay i'm a dad now i know what
you're going through
right now you're walking back and forth
you're singing lullabies you're probably
dead
tired why don't i help out okay i know a
few lullabies
and as all america knows i have a very
pretty beautiful singing voice
so uh set your baby in front of the tv
right now
and i'm gonna sing him or her to sleep
for you you can take a break
and since we've got john mayer here
tonight i thought we'd ask him to sing
along is that cool
i'd love to let's do this thing let's
get some uh here we go
alan uh you want to uh dim the lights
please and we'll uh do this
uh john you ready to go i am going okay
here we go we're gonna do this nice
thing
oh yeah
little baby go to sleep
fall into a slumber d
let me sing a soothing song
you won't be awake for long
for long for long
it's a funny thing you know
your comprehension's very low
it doesn't matter what i say
as long as it's this gentle
[Music]
i need one more rehearsal
subway shooting lion's den
global warming brad and jen
radiation birth control
ashley got booed
[Music]
now let's take a short time out
for all my viewers who feel left out
here's some stuff for you to see
mom and dads please turn baby
away from the tv screen
[Music]
away from
the tv screen
tv screens
now i'm sure fast asleep
dreaming dreams of lambs and sheep
patrick wilson will be out next
to mom and dad now go have sex
and watch us watch us
be right back